Speaker 1: Real quick, I want to mention that
there was a bizarre and horrifying event in
Philadelphia that kind of went wacky.
White supremacists participated in a rally,
a march in Philadelphia, meant to be about
supposed election integrity, by which they
mean that Trump really won.
Check out this report from Huff Post.
A white supremacist group based in Texas attempted
a march on Philadelphia over the Independence
Day weekend, but had to celebrate the holiday
the Confederate way.
They literally ran away from the people of
Philadelphia, Michael Croma, a police officer
in the city, told the local ABC station PVI.
About 200 masked and khaki clad members of
the Patriot Front organization, listed as
a white nationalist hate group by the Southern
Poverty Law Center, marched on the city in
the Saturday night incident, NBC Philadelphia
reported.
They chanted about the election and reclaim
America, engaged in pushing and shoving with
people and took a reporter's cell phone.
But that boldness quickly faded as more residents
turned out.
They started engaging with citizens of Philadelphia
who were none too happy about what they were
saying.
These males felt threatened and at one point
somebody in their crowd threw a type of smoke
bomb to cover their retreat.
They're treating this like a tactical event.
They covered their retreat.
Philly Mayor Jim Kenney said he was appalled
that the group chose his city for its.
Demonstration.
Saying, while we respect everyone's right
to exercise free speech, our administration
stands against everything these groups represent.
Racism, intolerance and hate have no place
here.
There are videos of white supremacist groups
using what looked to be toy shields to protect
themselves.
It's all just absolutely and completely bizarre.
One member of the white supremacist group
was hit and fell when another member pulled
the trucks roll up, door down, slamming him
in the head in the process.
I'm not going to play the clip, but it is
there.
There were no arrests, nor were there reports
of injuries or damage.
So of course, I'm not for violence of any
kind.
I'm not for violence by the protesters.
And assuming that it is not in self-defense,
I'm also not for violence against these people.
A couple of interesting notes here.
No.
One, it's great that this went a different
way than Charlottesville, Virginia, early
in Donald Trump's presidency.
Of course, you never want to see that.
Number two, it's not lost on me that the people
that are clinging on to the Trump really one
narrative include all sorts of of radicals,
including, in this case, white nationalists.
And it's good that the government is paying
attention to the fact that that's a reality.
And then number three, again, does it matter
whether the white nationalists really think
Trump won or whether they are just using it
as an excuse to get out there and cause chaos?
It doesn't really matter much the same way
that there's people who say Trump's anti-Semitic
and then the counter is Trump's not anti-Semitic.
His son in law is Jewish.
His daughter converted to Judaism.
His grandkids are Jewish.
Oh, but you could still have Jewish family
and benanti it doesn't matter if he emboldens
and coalesces the anti Semitic people and
the white nationalists.
What is deep in Trump's mind doesn't actually
really matter.
The actions are what matter here, and the
actions in this particular case are that all
sorts of radicals are getting involved in
this.
I hate I feel stupid even calling it election
integrity movement.
It's really a wreak havoc and try to steal
the election movement.
All of those groups are getting involved and
we'll see what impact they have on the twenty,
twenty two election.
Quite frankly